the super successful cbs primetime drama
csi returns to its roots this fall with
csi vegas and i had a chance to speak
with two of its stars pamela newsom who
plays lead investigator maxine roby and
mandeep dylan as ali rajan
maxine is a is a as a person is a woman
who loves science
you know
she gets to do this job that makes the
like it's like a mother hen that makes
science all these amazing scientific
experiments and and and possible and
ally tell me how your two characters
interact in the show and what's coming
up this season that might be a little
unexpected from what we've seen so far
maxine really
has a chance to mentor ali um and kind
of help ali out with some with the very
hard case that's coming up for ali um
maxine's there like you're she's her
her rock in a way and she kind of gives
her the tools in order to be able to
deal with
all the craziness of the job it's a nice
relationship that they have
and what's important what i was just
thinking as she was talking sherry is
that people that do these jobs
they kind of burn out at 10 years
you know it's a lot to carry seeing all
that stuff but what's also brilliant
about it is that we get to bring it
to the screen so that people could see
how this science is made how this
science how these crimes are solved and
we got to touch a little bit on this
week's episode because uh former
colleague david hodges uh who's such a
good
wholesome clean
you know clean cut guy from years past
but he's implicated with in tampering
with evidence how's that all going to
turn out can you give us a little hint
it's actually a massive threat on the
whole lab and the whole justice system
and
and what they're using evidence in court
like it's it's a lot um which will take
us throughout the series
to find out what's what and what's going
on we get to go and visit a swingers
club as you do
everyone would do in vegas wow as you do
in vegas um yeah me and my character and
matt lauria's character who plays joshua
folsom we have a lot of fun that's when
is tough
well i can't wait to see that part and
ladies can i just say to our viewers
here for the record i have not been to a
swingers club so not all of us in vegas
do it
yes sherry yes yes there is a future
i haven't lived all my life yet have my
ladies